I haven't played the bad guy for a while
I just finished Thor Ragnarok in which I
play Loki again but mercifully the bad
boy pants were passed on to cate
blanchett this time around who's playing
the goddess of death which is
significantly more bad than the god the
god of mischief I think in the bad boy
stakes but let's put it this way Doctor
Strange has kind of very intensely
cerebral time-bending powers last time
we saw at the end of called the dark
world you haven't seen it you just slow
so I'm gonna spoil something about it
because it came out 2013 so I got a
spike in all of the black world Loki's
on the throne what happened to Odin so
maybe Doctor Strange has to help out
with that particular conundrum
oh my god Tom Hiddleston dropping all
the bobs so he basically confirmed that
hella is going to be death in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like Thanos is cosmic
death so I'm gonna explain what's going
on but he also teased Doctor Strange as
well there is a new round of the
spider-man giveaway going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce the winners at the end be sure
to click that Bell to enable alerts so
you don't miss anything
so this is huge Tom Hiddleston was
actually at the Golden Globes accepting
for the night manager which is a drama
series with Hugh Laurie it was like a
completely separate thing but he just
confirmed hella will be the Marvel
Cinematic Universe version of death
which me know maybe surprised maybe not
be a surprise just because they tend to
simplify things like they have Kate
freaking Blanchette one of the best
living actresses right now playing one
of the biggest most powerful characters
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe it
makes sense that they would try to find
another way to incorporate her into
other big storylines like Avengers
infinity war in Thanos so top 10 things
about this number 10 this is all based
on Jack Kirby's Ragnarok storyline which
was like the last couple issues of Thor
that he wrote for Marvel before he went
to DC and did New Gods stuff if you want
to read those issues it starts with Thor
number 175 and goes through 177 so it's
like the last three issues that Jack
Kirby ever wrote on the original Thor
comic book number nine she's just as
powerful as normal as guardians but in
the comics this is a little bit
different she has a pact with the cosmic
entity death which in the comics is like
a separate thing that allows her to
collect a portion of the souls of dead
as guardians and bring them to her realm
so she is kind of like a smaller version
of the devil for Asgard but she in her
own right shares a lot of the same
physiology as normal as guardians so she
does have magical abilities she curses
Thor with immortality she's able to
restore people to life she has certain
magical abilities that go beyond what
you would think the doctor strange or
Loki would be able to do so she's on par
with the big magical beings of the
marvel universe she is the daughter of
Loki but not the current version of the
character she's the daughter of a Loki
from a previous version of Ragnarok so
Ragnarok is the cycle of death and
rebirth where the gods die new gods are
born in their place some are resurrected
so she's the daughter of a previous
version of low-key but Odin is the one
who appoints her goddess of the realm of
death so it's sort of like exile you can
see how hella might be a little bit
bitter about that so they might
incorporate that into the movie as well
like she's been banished for all these
years from Asgard even though she is the
daughter of an Asgardian number eight
during that original Ragnarok storyline
while Loki is taking over Asgard hella
steals a portion of Odin's soul like as
if he were in the odinsleep steals a
portion of his soul and creates a being
called infinity with it now Marvel is
that like a couple different versions of
infinity in the comics but number seven
this version of infinity had a child
known as Eon which was responsible for
protecting the celestial axis which was
like the life force that flowed through
the world tree which was kind of like
the way the Asgardians used to describe
the universe number six
Hellas main weapon is the knight sword
it's a magical sword that's on par with
a lot of other Asgardian weapons it's
not quite as powerful as Thor's hammer
which itself is actually a living entity
I'll explain how Thor's hammer is really
alive there's like a consciousness to
the hammer and it doesn't really speak
that often but hellas nights or is one
of the most powerful weapons next to
Odin's spear which is technically the
most powerful in Thor's hammer there's
always a lot of arguments about who has
the most powerful weapon technically you
would say Thor's hammer is the most
powerful but because Odin has the
odinforce and wields it through the
spear the spear becomes the most
powerful weapon so the most powerful God
typically has the most powerful weapon
but if Thor is doing his job and the
Hammers working the way it's supposed to
it would be the most powerful weapon so
number five the next most powerful
weapon that she actually gets to use is
Twilight the sword of Fire Lord Surtur
who is a big figure in Ragnarok so
Serdar himself has a long history
fighting against Odin Thor has to battle
him back into submission but he's so
powerful that he has to use several
different artifacts to do it and they've
had a lot of battles during the comics
but the odinforce itself was created
when odin first trapped fire Lords order
in his realm which is down here on the
world tree so the way you view this is
the way the Asgardians view the universe
itself so you have Hellas realm down
here nifflheim right under Midgard which
is you know sort of like the mortal
plane in Asgard up here at the top
although technically Valhalla is the
Asgardian version of heaven it does
exist in Marvel Comics but the way you
see like the balance here is that Odin
is God he protects the nine realms their
version of the devil
is hella she presides over the realm of
death collects a portion of the souls so
even though hella resides over the realm
of death number four
fire Lords Serdar very important in the
takeover of Asgard
so Loki is planning to take control of
Asgard makes a pact with hella but
separately also releases fire Lords
order from his realm so that he can run
amok in go crazy hella didn't wield his
sword till much later in the comics but
you can see how they all work together
to create this chaos where Loki was
trying to take over Asgard but hella has
her own plans which provides for number
three the opportunity for Loki to not be
the villain of the story he was a
villain of sorts for the first two
movies much less so during Thor the dark
world still very bad but he really just
wants to rule so when he makes his
Faustian bargain as he tends to do she
storms Asgard forcing Loki to make a
bargain width or to try and fix
everything so that he gets to be the
hero of his own story even though he
created this problem in the first place
number two this provides the entry point
for Doctor Strange so that he can help
Loki and Thor locate Odin restore his
that has been stolen from him so that he
can regain the odinforce in fight off
hella in the minions of Ragnarok thorn
hope very important to this equation but
because this video is a little bit more
about hella we talk about number one
Thanos in his relationship with death
and how that's going to change in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
because as it seems like the Marvel
movies are now combining the cosmic
entity death with the Asgardian version
of death in hella with Kate Blanchet
then Thanos will try to make a pact with
her because she wants to destroy the
universe Thanos in the comics is in love
with death so it's a very meta concept
being in love with the idea of death but
because Marvel has like a physical
cosmic entity death that you can reach
out and touch he literally loves her
wants to make her his bride
but hilariously she rejects him and it
leads to his ultimate undoing
now infinity war the movie isn't going
to be exactly like the infinity comic
book storyline but until fan OHS
assembles all of the infinity gems and
wears the gauntlet Cate Blanchett's
character hella will be the most
powerful villain inside this Marvel
Universe not including Dormammu who will
become a much bigger thing later in
Marvel phase 4 so that's getting a
little ahead of the story so we can talk
about it down the road congratulations
to the latest spider-man giveaway winner
made an X you win a $20.00 comiXology
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video if you
want to request a special Marvel movie
video or something related just leave it
in the comments well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
all about the Planet Hulk storyline
that's going to be happening during
Ragnarok and you can click here for my
Justice League preview of all the
costumes thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys in the next
you